よろしくお願いします
今日はこのコースの最後の話ですが
一応今日はこの実践のところ
いわゆる方法 方法論のところなんです
と で 最初からいろいろ釈尊の立場から仏教のことを
お釈迦様の教えを説明してきましたけど
いろいろ気に入らないこととか
納得いかないこととかあったかもしれません
で 誰でもあまり納得いかないのは
この すべては苦であるということなんですね
で また生老病死は苦であるということはもう納得いかないんですね
で でも私たちはそれにはもうものすごい真っ向から反対して
もう苦ですよという立場でお釈迦様そうおっしゃってるんだと言っていたんです
そう言っておかなくちゃいけないんですね
なぜならば 私たちは納得いかないんだからといって
だからといって釈尊がおっしゃったことを曲がったりすると
それは科学的 学問的な話にはならないんですね
お釈迦様がそうおっしゃったんだから
それは私にとってはどうしようもないことで
皆様にとってもどうしようもないことで
人がそういうふうに言ったんだから
で すべては苦であると
そこでなぜそういうふうに言ったかということは
その人の考え方から理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで説明したのは この
で 生老病死 あるいは人生そのものなんですね
生老病死という言葉でまとめているのは
人生そのものは苦しみであると
不完全であると 空しいものであるというと
この納得いかないのはちょっとおかしいんだと
で 逆に質問するとそれは理解できるんですね
じゃあ我々は我々の人生にものすごく納得しているんですかと
これで素晴らしいんだとしっかりとわかっているんですかと
幸福に満ち溢れて 楽しみで楽しみで幸福に我々は生きているんですか？何も心配ことはないんですかと
自分の生き方 命と命に対してはと
そういうふうに逆に自分に聞いてみた方がいいんです
ただ単に何か納得いかないなではなくて
人生は苦しみだというと
なんかちょっと暗いではないかとか
それはおかしいではないかとかね
そういうふうに思うこと自体が
我々の 私が使っている言葉はへ理屈なんですけど
我々は論理的な人間でないってことなんですね
合理的な 論理的な この
リアルな世界で生きている人間ではないんだと
ただ自分の感覚で 感で喋っているだけではないかと
人生は素晴らしくあってほしいという
まあ望みがあるんですね
その望みから やっぱり人生は素晴らしいぞと言ってしまうではないかと
それで じゃあ人生はどんなものかと客観的に見てみましょうと
客観的に見てみると いろんなものは出てくるんですね
まあ楽しみも出てくるわ
苦しみも出てくるわ それはちゃんと具体的に分けてみると
楽しみの方が少ないし
苦しみの方が多いんですね
ですから それは客観的に分けてみなきゃ
1時間の一時間の自分の人生の中で何秒間すごい楽しかったかと
何秒間苦しみかったかと
ちゃんとチャートに丸とバツと入れてみるとわかるものなんですね
ですから 我々にはちゃんとこの本当に生きることは大変か
あるいは幸福で満ち溢れているかということは
実験して試すことは簡単にできるんです
たった 1時間  2時間 ごく普通な生き方をしながら
まあ秒単位は早いかもしれませんだけど
1分単位でもいいんです
1分ごとに その1分はどういうものですかと
その場合は苦と楽と まあ中とかね
どっちでもないという三段階に分けて
そこに丸を入れてみれば 1
時間の後で計算できますから
60個の印が出ているんだから
そういう風に科学的に見てほしいんですね
生き方は そういう風に見ると
やっぱり苦の方があまり大きくて
楽の方が少ないんですと
そこで具体的に合理的に至れる結論は
人生は苦しみで不満であるということなんですね
ですから それは別に単なるもう科学的な客観的な判断であって
別に我々にとって別に恨みがあったわけじゃないと
僕はそこら辺ずっと説明してきました
で なんでお釈迦様がそういうことを発見してお話ししますかというと
我々はどこかで間違っているんですね
人生は それは望みを事実にしてしまっちゃうんです
だから人生は幸福であってほしいというのは人間の望みであって
それだから故に人生は幸福ですというのはちょっと論理合わないんですね
ちょっともうちょっと明確に考えましょう
命は我々の生命は幸福であってほしいと
という望みがあるんだ
で 故に人生は幸福ですよと言えますかね
で 私はもっとたとえで言えば分かります
例えば ある高校生がこう思う
私は大学で博士号を取りたいという望みがある
故に私は博士ですと言えますかね
私は博士 なぜ博士ですか？私は大学に入って博士まで博士号を取りたいと思っているんだから
とならないんですね で
不思議なこと そうたとえで言ったら
これは屁理屈だとわかるでしょうに
でも人生について幸福になりたいということは望みであって
故に人生は幸福でありますよというのはちょっとおかしいことで
もし人生は幸福であるならば
幸福になりたいという望みはなくなるでしょうに
もう全てが望み消えるでしょうに
その場合は ああなりたい
こうなりたいと何もない
もう全部消える 落ち着く
この我々の必死な戦いがそこでストップになる
ゴールに達したことになっちゃうんですね
そこで釈迦さんが じゃあそうなってほしいんですね
じゃあ最高たる幸福になってみなさいと
こんなあっちこっちね
寄り道ばっかり走らないで
きちんと面と向かって問題にぶつかって
我々の問題を解決して幸福になってみたらいかがでしょうかと
私は幸福になりたい 故に幸福ですよという理屈を使わないで
幸福になりたいと幸せになりたいという気持ちは
完全たる幸せ 幸福 気安感を感じてないんだからなんです
感じても感じなくても
また一般的には私は別に何の問題もないと思っている方々はいくらでも世の中にはいますよ
人生は問題ですよという人々は少ないし
大体大勢の方々はそれなりに頑張って
人生はもう頑張ってますから
問題はないんです 社会の中で問題の人々は少ないでしょうに
何も問題なく 普通に幸せで平和で生きている人々の方が多いので
それは当たり前のことで
もし人口の半分以上問題だらけの人間になったら
もう国は成り立たなくなっちゃいますからね
世界は ですから 一般的に見れば
我々は平和で無事で幸せでは生きています
仕事もそれなりにうまくいっているし
家庭も家族もそれなりにうまくいっていると
必要な収入もそれなりにあるんだと
体の調子も別にどうってことはないんだと
健康だというぐらいだったら
人間の中で九十パーセントぐらいはだいたいそんな状態なんですね
で 釈尊 じゃあそれだったら仏教はいらないのではないかということにもなりますけど
でも そういう人々にしても
その必死になって努力しなくちゃ
そのわずかな幸福は消えてしまうんですね
そういう人々もちょっと間違えばすべて壊れてしまうんですね
いくら健康で大変収入があるんだと言っても
ほんのちょっと間違えば全部壊れてしまうんですね
それから いつでも我々はどこかで満たされてないという実感があるんですね
今私は喋っているのは問題の方々ではなくて
何も問題なく健康的で幸せで生きている方々の場合なんですね
そういう人々にしても
より良くなりたいという希望があるんです
昨日よりは今日頑張らなくちゃと
昨日も今日も昨日と全く同じペースでいいとは思わないんですね
それでほんのちょっと間違えば
全部その幸福も崩れてなくなってしまうし
そういうことはいつでもあるんですね
ですから 正しければ 人々に私はこう聞けば
幸福になりたい方々は手を挙げてくださいと言ったら
みんな我々は幸福に別になりたくはないんだと
大きなお世話だよというならば
その方々は幸福なんですね
大きなお世話ですよ こんな幸福なんか要りませんと
でもそう言えますかね
例えば私は商売はもっとうまくいく
いろいろ方法を知ってますよと
教えてあげますと言ったら
いい加減にしなさい 大きなお世話だよと
と言えるならば もうその人はOKなんでしょ
ですから この でもそんな人は世の中でいないんですね
いくら幸福な人間であろうとも
より健康的になりたいとかね
もっと調子よくなりたいと思わない人はいませんしね
ということは事実であって
ですから 生きる我々の生命のこの流れの中で常にあるのは不満というものなんですね
不満 満たされてないという実感
その満たされてないという実感で我々は生きているんです
生きる衝動は満たされてないという実感なんです
もし満たされたら生きる衝動も消えちゃうんです
よく考えていただきたいんです
いつでも我々の心の中でもうちょっとよく
もうちょっと良ければ良かったんではないかという気持ちがあるんだから頑張ってるんです
自分の小さな子供を見たら
この子はもうちょっと良くできた方がいいんじゃないかなという気持ちがあるんですね
それで子供にいろんなことを教えたり
塾 塾に出したり いろんな稽古事を教えたり
いろんなことをするんです
いくら美しいで生まれても
もうちょっと良くなった方がいいんじゃないかと思ってるんだから
みんな自分のダイエットのことやら体重のことやらああだこうだ全部気になっちゃうんです
髪型やら唇の色はどうしましょうかとか
服の色とこの服とこの口紅色が合いますかないかとかね
そこまできめ細かいところまで
今日のネックレスはこの服にどうかなとかね
服には合うんだけど この髪型にはどうかなとか
大変でしょうね それでみんな生きてるんだ
幸せだと言うんです その生きてるんだ
幸せだというこの衝動は何ですかというと
もうちょっとよくよければいいなという気持ちでしょうに
例えば男性の場合でも
いくら知識的でいろんな立派な仕事をしていても
いつでも何か雑誌読んだり
新聞を真面目に読んだりとか
いつでももうちょっと頭に知識情報あった方がいいな
もうちょっとあった方がいいなとか
男性の方々はもう年取って新聞やら読めなくなるまで
いろんな情報を頭に積み込んで積み込んでいるんじゃないんですかね
これでいいと思ってないんですね
これで私はすべて修済しました
今日からは写真も新聞も本も読めませんと
という男性はいませんね
いつでもなんとか何とか知ろう知ろうとしているんです
ですから それは女性であろうが男性であろうが
我々は何か満たされてない
どこかちょっと納得いかない
どこかであるんですね
そういう気持ちが それで生きてるんです
それは普通の世の中で人間の生き方
だからそれはそのままお釈迦様がおっしゃってるだけ
満たされてない状態に渇愛と言うんです
そこですーっと頑張る
いくら頑張っても不満という状態がある
それで最高な幸福ですよという究極的な喜悦感を味わったことはない
一度も それ味わったらそれっきりでもう何もやることがなくなっちゃいますから
ですから それに仏教では苦しみと言うんです
だから生命っていうのは苦しみという構造でできてあって
この渇愛という衝動で生きているんだという説明はしているんです
そこで仏教の話いきなり言うと
みんな納得いかないのは
この世界にこの満たされてない状態の海の中に溺れてるんだからなんです
私たち知っている生き方っていうのは
この満たされてない 何とかして満たさなくちゃいけないという気持ちで生きているんですね
ですから それは大事 ありがたいものになっているんです
人間にとってはこの苦しみっていうのはありがたいもので
渇愛っていうのはありがたいもので
そこなくなったら あ やべえと
どうしようかと 生きていられないんではないかと
と怖くなっちゃうんです
まあそれだけなんですね
仏教にちょっと納得いかないところは
それで我々はこのお釈迦様が人間に全く違う道を歩んだらどうですかと
この同じ道で終わりない道ですね
これは というのは お腹が空いたら満たされてない
ご飯食べてもこの味には完璧に満足できない
食べてまたお腹が空く
疲れてくると もうすごく不安定な状態で眠くなる
眠ってもそれで完璧に治ったわけじゃないし
また眠くなると 終わりがないんですね
ずっと続くんです で それは簡単な論理でお釈迦様は説明するんですね
満たされてないものは
満たされてないこの欠けてる部分を補おうと思って
さらに欠けてる部分を探し求めてるんだと
そうすると探し求めてもそれまた欠けてるんですね
探した部品は欠けてるんだから
そうすると結果はまだ満たされてないと
じゃあもう一つ探そうと
また欠けてる部品を探し求めて
それに入れてみると結果は欠けていると
それはいくらやっても同じことだと
いわゆる機械で考えてみてください
例えば 皆様の家にあるラジカセなんかちょっと故障したんだと
そこで何か欠けてるんで
その場合は部品 そこで不完全なんですね
動きませんだから それで修理すれば動くだろうというふうに想像する
それで そこら辺にある何か品物をそこに挿してみると
ヘアピンでももう何でもいいんです
まあまあ 金属だからということで中に入れてみると
入れてもラジカセは動かないんですね
結果は欠けていると これでダメだから他のものを入れてみようと入れてみても
それでもそれは不完全なんですね
その働きで一生頑張っても
ラジカセは直るわけじゃないんですね
勝利するわけじゃないんですね
で 人生も同じく我々は欠けてるなと感じている
完成にならなくちゃという希望もある
それで探し求めているものは全部欠けているものばっかりなんですね
それでいくら頑張っても
この不完全な状態は消えることはありません
それは体験してみてください
これを我々の人生だよとお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんですね
だから私 自分の旦那さんで完璧に満足している奥様がいないし
自分の奥さんで完璧に満足している男性もいないし
子供で私の子供は世界一完璧だという両親もいないし
自分の母親は世界で完璧だという思う人もいませんし
どこを見ても まあ口では言いますけどね
でも実際にはそうじゃないんです
私の母親は世界一素晴らしいよとね
もう言う男が 男の人って結構いますよ
それは母親が完璧だからではなくて
母親は一生懸命やってくれたことに自分の感謝なんですね
自分の旦那さんがもう世界で素晴らしいよというお母さんたちもいるんですよ
いるんですが それは自分の旦那が特別完璧な
もう超越した人間というわけじゃなくて
自分のことをよく心配それでよく面倒見てくれたことに感謝しているだけなんです
そこを間違わないでください
世の中で私の子は素晴らしいよという人
お母さんたちいますけど
だからといって素晴らしいということではない
それはただ我々の感想やら気持ちなんですね
そういうことで で 満たされてないことで我々は生きている
それで探し求めるものは全部不完全なもので
ですから 決してこの欠けているものはきちんと完璧になるわけはないと
ずっと続くんですね それは
それに仏教ではそれに輪廻と言うんですね
回るぐるぐるぐるぐる回っちゃうんだと
いくら努力したっても何か欠けてるんです
いくら頑張っても何か欠けてるんです
その働きで死んでもまた生まれ変わっちゃうんだと
同じ働きなんです この生まれ変わるということは
本当は我々人間にはなかなか理解できない話なんですが
仏教の立場から見れば
もうごく普通の当たり前の論理的な話なんですね
今も今の状態を客観的に分析して見ちゃうと終わりがないんですね
人の生命見ちゃうと この人は走り回ったと生きて
だから産声をお上げながら走り回っちゃうでしょうに
産声自体も生きていきたいという努力でしょうに
死にたくないと それからそのスタートしたこのレースを
この走ることを終わらないんです
ずっと走ってるんです
いくら走っても 何か欠けているんです
何か欠けてる 欠けてるんだから走ってるんです
何か欠けてる 走ってるで生きてるんです
そこで年取っても人間が必死で生きている
最後の息を引くまでも必死になって生きている
それで最後の息を止まったら
これで私は幸福だ 人生は完璧になったという気持ちにならないでしょうね
その時も同じことで もう最後の息自体さえも不完全だから
それでいいということはないんですね
誰も思ってますかね 最後の息を吸ったところで人生は完璧になるんだと思ってます？思っていない
思ってるんだったら みんなすぐ自殺するんです
なぜならその時 最後の息はすぐ吸えますから
誰も思ってないんです
だから死ぬ瞬間でも できればあと三回でも呼吸したいという気持ちがあるのは普通なんです
そういうことで 我々は死んでも
この体の形がなくなることは死ぬということというんだけど
そのエネルギーの生命体としてのこの満たされてない
何とかしなくちゃというこの機能は続くんだと
それはエネルギーの不滅論と同じく
もう続けていっちゃうんです
それで輪廻という概念というのは
何のことなく仏教で使っているんです
それは別に理解できないならば
それはそれで構いませんし
まあ当たり前の考え方としてあるんですけれども
で そこで科学的な答えが
具体的な答えが 我々この探しているものが欠けているんだから
この探し方を変えて 正しいものを欠けている部分にぴったし合うものを付けてもらえば
そこで人生は完璧なんです
それで探すことは全部終わるんです
そこで走ることは止まるんです
そこで輪廻も止まるんです
そこで全ての苦しみが止まってしまっちゃうんです
それは仏教で解脱というんです
いわゆるあ ついにやったという気持ちなんです
ついに見つかったぞという気持ちなんです
やっと見つかったと その瞬間で
ものすごくほっとするんです
そうでしょう 我々も例えばもう何か家で大事な品物なくなったと
それ探すは探すはないんだと
そこでもう例えば  仕事終わって8時に家に旦那さんが帰るんだと
帰るときはこれどうしても必要ですよと
でもなくなって あるいは自分の結婚記念日に旦那さんにもらった指輪でしたよと
それでまた今日 また次の結婚記念日で
あれはなくなったよと言っちゃったら
ちょっと立場が悪いんだからね
で 探すんだ見つからないと
なんだかすごく不安なんですね
探すは探すは探すは探せば下がる
探すほどどんどん不安やら苦しみやら出てくるんですね
どうしよう どこでなくなったんですかと
それで家中片っ端から探す
誰かに お友達にでも貸してあげたんではないかなとまた思い出したりする
そこで友達に電話してみる
電話するといきなりそれ聞こえませんだから
で いろんな方法で聞いたところで向こうに怒られると
そうすると友達の関係も悪くなっちゃうとか
そういういろんなトラブルを起こしちゃうんですね
このなくなった指輪を探して
とにかく旦那さんが8時に帰りますって
その前に探す そこでどこかにちょっと自分が冷蔵庫の上に敷いてた紙の下とか
どこかにちょっといたところで
なんとかもう他のことやって
ね 他の人とちょっともう叩こうと思ったところでポーンと落ちたんだと
見つかる瞬間でどうですかね
気持ちは 見つかった瞬間で
ものすごく気持ちよくて
すごくホッと あーよかった
ただ助かりましたと なぜなら我々は探したそのものが見つかったんだからなんです
それでもうそれっきりで探さないでしょうに
家中 何のことなくすごい気持ちよく自信があって生きていられますね
ですから この人間はどんな生命でも何か探しているんだけど
そのものが見つからないんです
見つかるものはもう何でかんでももう不完全なもので合わない
人生に合わせてみても
結果は不完全で だからぴったしと
この我々は探しているものを見つかったらいかがでしょうかと
そのためには 私はずっとこの４回もかけて喋ったような
すごく大胆な爆弾的な言葉で
この真理を言わなくちゃいけないんです
我々の普通の人間の道をもうダメですよと
それで何の意味もないんだと
脅しでも入れとかないと
その同じ道で行っちゃうんですね
ですから 結局は仏教こそが究極的な真の幸福論を喋ろうとしているんです
幸福論というよりは 真の幸福の道を喋ろうとしているんです
それで不幸な話はするんです
だってそれはどうしようもないんです
医者が我々を完全に病気を治したいと思った瞬間で
医者が我々の体の中で何を探すんですか？病気探すんです
本当に正直な素晴らしいお医者さんで
私を完全に治してあげたくなっちゃったと
それで医者があなたの髪の毛が艶々でいいですね
かっこいいですね この髪型とかね
あなたのこの眉毛って言うんですか
眉毛のこの描き方素晴らしいですね
そんなこと言うんですかね
そんなこと言ったっても何の意味もないんだから
あなたの指がなんかね
細くてすごいかっこいいとかね
そういう正しい医者だったら
そんなこと全部もうあっち行けという感じで
血圧が高いとかね コレステロールの値がちょっと高すぎですよと
体脂肪はちょっと多すぎですよとかね
そういう悪口ばっかり言うんです
あんた朝何食べるんですか？と
朝こういうダメですよと
朝はこういうこういう風に食べなさいと
一日どれぐらい運動しているんですか？と
今これこれダメですよとかね
それが正しい教え方なんですね
それで我々はあの医者が本当に悪い人やと
人の欠点ばっかり探してるんだと
私はこんなに綺麗に決まってるのに
高価な服を着て もうすごくきちんと
もう高価なアクセサリーをつけて
高価な香水をつけてきちんと決まってるのに
見ようともしないんだと
そういう風に仏教の世界でも
ちゃんとした幸福を喋りたいんだから
ちゃんとした幸福の道を喋りたいんだから
生命は苦しみであるということは喋らざるを得ないんです
それまた嘘でなく事実なんですよ
それで我々はこの探してるそのものを見つからなくちゃいけない
今日はそのお話をします
で 簡単に言えば幸福って何でしょうかね
皆様方 結構幸福を味わったことあるでしょ
そんな不幸に見えませんだからね
いくら見ても 結構人生幸福を味わったような顔をみんな持ってますし
だからその思い出してみてください
我々は結構人生ではね
まあ悪い方じゃないと
まあと言うでしょうね
それはもう丁寧な言葉で
まあ私の人生はまあそんなに悪い方じゃないという方は本当に幸福なんです
別に人間はもう立派な方々だから
私は素晴らしい何やっても成功してきましたと言えませんだからね
そんな大胆な話言えませんし
まああまり悪い方ではなかったというのは
もうそれぐらい言ったならば
もうかなりの幸福な人生でしょうし
ですから 皆様 皆様方は結構幸福を味わった経験がありますし
それで幸福って何でしょうかと
ちゃんと定義してみてください
このその定義はしないんだから
ちょっと間違うんです
いつでもこのきちんと我々の体験何者かときちんと定義っていうのは
このただ言葉の遊びのようなこと発見しなくちゃいけない
その幸福の場合も 我々幸福を感じた時
定義を忘れちゃうんです
それで幸福も消えてしまうんです
例えば一つの例なんですけど
皆様方どんなという幸福を感じるか分かりませんだけどね
ですから 具体的な例あれば
その場合は話しやすいんだけど
私には具体的な例はありませんので
もう勝手に例を作るんです
まあ一年間苦労して仕事をしましたと
それでお正月は何日間休みが取れると
まあ一応夏休みは何日間休みが取れる
自分がずっと昔からもうスイスに行きたかったんだと
昔から行きたかったんだから
色々スイスの情報やら色んな見たいところやら
全部もう見たり もう色んなものを頭にインプットしてあって
見たくてたまらないと
そこでやっと行けたんだと
休みも取れて 十分お金もあって
もう行けたんだ そこで行きて
もう飛行機からスイスの土に足を下ろした
そんなすごく幸福を感じちゃうんです
あ やっと行けたんだと
やっと来られたんだと
その瞬間は幸福なんです
若い人の例を出す 例えば若い
随分若い二人がいるんだと
ものすごく若いんだから
すごくあのまああまり自信もないんだから
例えば相手を気に入ってるんだ
気に入ってるんだけど
なんか話すのはちょっと怖い
ちょっと不安 まあなんていうか自信がない
そういう小さい時はね
誰にでもありますからね
なんか学校の教室の中でも
なんか気に入ってる相手がいるんだけど
なんかその方向では話しません
そこで話したいんだけど
仲良くしたいんだけど
なんかどうか自信がない
そこでなんとかの関係で学校のいろんな用事があるんだから
それでこの二人であんた方二人これやりなさいとか
なんとかとか言われてもらったら
それすごい楽しいでしょうに
いろんな喋る機会がその時あるんだから
そこでもうすごい真面目になって
もうそういう自分に回してきた仕事もちゃんとやって
それでお互いに仲良くなったならば
すごく幸福を感じるんでしょ
そこで我々はそういう幸福をいくらでも味わっているし
そこで じゃあそれが幸福かと
私はまたちょっとミスをさせてみたいんですね
そこで我々定義を間違っちゃうんです
理解を 幸福っていうのは
この子供二人が互いにまあなんとなく気になってるんだ
気に入ってるんだけど
もう話せないと それ話すことができたと
友達になることができたと
それで幸福やと思って定義ごまかして間違っちゃうんですね
その人に出会ったことが幸福だと
それは幸福じゃないんです
[背景音楽]その人に出会ったことで
心の中で生まれたこの感激
それが幸福なんです だから外国旅行するみんな幸福感じませんだから
私なんかはどこへ行ったって全く同じでつまらないんです
何のことなく 日本にいる時も自分の国にいる時も
他の国何のことなく 全く同じペースで生きてるんです
どこへ行ったっても そこにそれなりに色々買い物をするわ
あっちこっち歩いてみるわ
人と喋ったりするわ それで夜遅くなったら寝て
またもう帰る日は帰ると
だからどこへ行っても
そこら辺にいる友達なんかは全然誰もびっくりも何もないんです
私もないんで 何のことなく
例えば 1年  2年間にどこかへ国のいる友達のところに行ったって
何のことなく なんかただいまのような感じでうちに入っちゃうんです
ああやって それぐらい
まあまあ普通に見えちゃいますけど
ですから もし外国旅行することはすごい幸福だったら
すごくいつでも幸福になるはずなんですね
そうじゃないんです この心の中に生まれるその感激が幸福なんです
そこを覚えておいてください
で 女性の方に聞いたら
もう人生一番幸福だ 幸福の日は何ですかと
それは結婚式でしたとか
どうかな わかりませんだけど
大変苦しかったとか その日だけはと
あまりにしきたりが大きくてということは
それは置いておいて 例えばウェディングドレスですか
それを着ることはできて
結構豪華な結婚式できたんだと
それは女性の夢だと 乙女の夢だと
で ウェディングドレス着たことが幸福だと
じゃあ今着てみてください
それだったらそんなに高くないでしょ？あのウェディングドレスってのはものすごい安いでしょうに
自分で作ればね 一つウェディングドレス
まあ高価なものでもいいんだけど
作って家に入れておいて
幸福を感じたい時はすぐそれを着ておしゃれをして
幸福になりますかね そうすると幸福になるところが
自分が捕まって自分の旦那さんが病院に連れて行くかもしれません
先生 この女の人を何とかしてくださいと
病気だよと それで分かりますかね
幸福の論 幸福の定義を
ウェディングドレス着ること着ることができたことが幸福ではありません
その着た時が心の中に生まれたあの感激
あれが幸福なんです それで女性の方にも結婚適齢
まあ不幸せ年になったところで
素晴らしい男性に巡り合えたと
それでものすごい幸福を感じる
その時幸福 それで ああ
この人と一緒だったら一生幸福だよと計算して結婚すると
それでどんどんあの感激は冷めていくでしょうに
喧嘩もするでしょうに
旦那を家から追い出したくなるでしょうに
旦那を追い出せない場合は自分で家出するでしょうに
実家に帰りますとかだとか言いながら
ですから もしこの人に出会ったことで
私はこれほど幸福になったというならば
その人と結婚してからずっと一緒にいるでしょうに
それだったら 毎日毎日体中もう満ち溢れる感激で気絶感でいるはずなんですよね
だから人間っていうのは幸福になりたいんだけど
肝心なこの幸福って何ですかと
それをわかってないんです
それと男もひどい目に遭いますからね
自分の奥さんと一緒にいてすごく楽しかったのは若い時で
それでいろんな若い女の人を追っかけていってとか
もう大変地獄の味わいを味わっちゃうとかね
それは人生失敗するでしょうに
みんなもうほとんどの人々はこの幸福の定義知らないんだから
何が幸福でしたかとわからないんだから
人生はダメなんです そこでもう絵を描いて感激感激を味わえた人が
それで一生全てそれで絵を描くようになってしまっちゃうし
でもどんどんそれは幸福にならなくなっちゃうんです
ある音楽を聴いて 若者
だいたい若い人は音楽好きなんですけど
誰かの誰かの聴いたところでものすごく幸福を感じて
感激をして その人々を追いかけたりして
それでそれからもう別に面白くなくなっちゃうんですね
あの刺激消えてしまうんですね
消えてしまうんだけど
またまた追っかけていくんです
ですから 本当のとこは幸福というのは美味しいご飯食べたんだ
食べられるんだから幸福じゃなくて
何か食べる時 心がすごく喜びを感じるんだと
そこに幸福があるんです
あの人に見ぐらいて幸福じゃなくて
その人に巡り会ったことで
自分の心の中で何か変化が起きたんです
幸福の波が生まれたんです
それが幸福なんです そこである問題は
なんであの人に巡り会えて幸せだという人が
その人と一緒になったところで
まあ十年十五年になっちゃうと
もうあなたいなくても大丈夫
平気やと いると面倒くさくてうるさいんだと言えるようになるんでしょうかね
で そこでこういう事実あるんです
あの伊勢エビ食べてものすごく楽しかったと
すごい幸福だと それだったら 1週間
2週間 毎日伊勢海老食べだけ食べてみてください
見たくもなくなっちゃうんです
昼ご飯も伊勢海老で 夜も伊勢海老で考えると
やっぱりそんなできるくはないと思っちゃうでしょうに
そんな贅沢できないんだと
できないわけないんだけど
覚悟を決めて 1週間伊勢海老ばっかり食べますよと
そんなにもね そんなにできないほどお金かかるわけじゃないんだから
やってみたら 番目は番の昼ご飯に食べると
なんて幸福かと思っちゃいますよ
それで夜は？夜は伊勢海老
やっぱり贅沢だなと これは
次の日もそんなことになっちゃうとちょっと違うんです
次の日も昼も夜も伊勢海老になったら
次の日もそうなったらもう知ってるんです
朝 昼 昼はまあなんて伊勢海老でしょうと
なんだと  1週間目になっちゃうと見たくもなくなっちゃうんです
その時はまあただのおにぎりだけでいいんだと思うことはあり得るんでしょう
あの刺激が消えちゃうんですね
繰り返しちゃうと で そこは事実なんです
だから 何か物に出会って刺激を感じても
2回目 そのものに出会うと
その刺激を感じなくなっちゃう
で そこには何か訳があるんです
私のこの刺激を感じる私の心も心は変化している
その心を支えている体も変化している
体変わる が変わる 心が変わると体が変わる
また 巡り合うた出会ったとか言っても一回きりなんです
二度と巡り合わないんです
世の中全ては一回きり
一回きり でも我々は一回きりだと思わないんです
ある人に巡り合えたと
その人と一緒になる それでKさんは死ぬまでその人と一緒にいようと
でも事実はその人と会えるのは一回きり
きりなんです 全部消えていっちゃうんです
それをわからなくて 探してるんです
同じものを 同じものになっちゃったらすっごくつまらなくなるんです
それで仏教は無常論を教えるんです
すべては無常だ すべては瞬間しか存在しないんだ
一回きりだ この体も光の速度と同じ速さで変化しているんです
新しい体に生まれ変わってるんです
私の心はもっと速さで変化しているんです
それを体験したら あの強烈な感激
刺激はずっと味わうことはできるんです
一回きりだから 二度食べたら美味しくないでしょうに
これは人生で一度しか食べられませんよと
というものがあるならば
その時はすごい感動するし
例えばね じゃあ例えに戻りますけど
食べる時はある人があまりにも幸福で
一回食べたものはもう二度と食べないんだと
一回食べたものは食べられませんだけど
同じものは二度と食べない
毎日全く新しいものを食べてるんだ
味も作り方も何でも新しいんだと言うと
その人にとっては 1日の 3食っていうのはすごい大胆なものなんです
朝食べたことは 生まれて初めて食べるもので
昼食べたことは生まれて初めて食べたもので
夜食べるものは生まれて初めて食べるもの
次の朝になったらまた生まれて初めて食べるもの
そうすると 食べる楽しみっていうのは消えないでしょうに
ずっと楽しい はずなんです
まあ事実でそんなことはありえませんから
人間食べるものはものすごく数が決まられているんだからね
だから我々は事実上はそれできませんんだけど
考えてみたらね なんで結婚式っていうのは女性にとっては大変な出来事ですか？というと
それは二度とできないだからでしょ
もう二度十度でもできますけど
結婚は ウェディングドレスも着られますけど
でもやっぱりどこかでまあ歳も年
歳になっちゃうしね 父親に大変愛されていて
娘で娘で じゃあ親嫁に行くぞという感じでウェディングドレス着るとすごい感動的で
ものすごく気持ちいいんです
それでどこかでもバツ 1に2に3になったところで
また今度大げさにウェディングウェディングやり直そうと思ったっても
誰もあまり歓迎しませんね
またかよと こっちであげるものなんて言いますか
祝儀？祝儀あげてももうきりがないんだと
いい加減にしろという状態になりますから
やっぱり一回きりだから
一生の思い出の幸福感
そこにあるんです そこで不思議なことは
なんでそれだったら人間にこの一回きりの論理を正しく理解できないかと
事実は世の中はすべて一回きりなんです
二度とないんです 今我々は過ごしている
この 1 秒間戻ってくれますか？戻ってこれませんでしょうに
今の瞬間って体も次にもう年取って変わってるんだから
体で見るんじゃなくて
やっぱり素粒子のレベルで
それを素粒子みたいな感じで見なくちゃいけないんだ
体も 素粒子だと思っちゃえばずっと変化することわかるでしょうに
心もずっと変化していくんだと
二度と同じ心生まれないんだとわかるでしょうに
それわかったら一回きりの感激はずっとあります
瞬間 瞬間 一回きりだから
それで人間の幸福を誰が妨げてますかというと
無常に逆らう我々が妨げてるんです
永遠になりたがってるでしょうに
魂があるんだと 私の大事な命だとかね
だから永遠に仏様待ってるんだとかね
神様が永遠に待ってるんだとか
我々に神様に永遠な命を与えてくれたんだとかね
そういう概念で 人間のあの究極な幸福を消えちゃう
で そういう宗教を信仰しなくても
人間の心の中でいつでもそれあるんです
何ですかと あれはなんていうのと
続けてほしいと 同じもの
自分の命でもずっとあってほしいと
会社の経済状態良くなったらずっとその状態でいてほしいと
若い人と結婚したら その若さがずっとあってほしいと
なんだかんでも永遠に続けてほしいという気持ちがあるんで
それはもう宗教を信仰している方々は宗教の教えられてるんだからしょうがないんだけど
宗教を信じてない方々はもう永遠になりたいって気持ちがあるんですね
消えるのは嫌なんです
子供たちが大きくなるとすごく嫌なんです
大きくなって一人独立しちゃうでしょうに
親に逆らうでしょうに
あれすごく嫌なんですね
昔は本当に可愛かったのにと泣いちゃうんです
よくママが言うことを聞いてくれて
本当にお父さんとよく遊んでくれて
すごく可愛かったのにとか悩んだりまでするんです
あの可愛らしい子供でずっといてほしいと
それで我々は自分で生きながら地獄を作って苦しんでるんです
ですから お釈迦様は幸福を得たい人は無常を体験すると
無常を体験するものは
すべての苦しみを乗り越えて幸福を味わうんだと
その事実を唱えているんです
だから この一回きりの論を幸福なんです
そこで今日は方法論なんですけど
皆様も幸福になりたければ
これは 1番目の方法として言いますけど
これはもう一番大事な道で
全ては瞬間瞬間消えていくこと
その目でものの世の中を見てください
この瞬間の出会い  二度とないんだ
だから瞬間瞬間 なんで思い存分刺激いっぱいで感激いっぱいで生きていられないんですかね
人と会うと なんでその人と今日初めて会うんだという気持ちにならないんですかね
知恵ある人にはそれできるんです
でも 知恵と世俗のよろこび
もうものすごい隔たりがあんまりも大きいんです
から 口では言えませんだけど
心の中ではあるんです
ですから この まあもっと面白おかしく言うならば
毎日朝起きて子供たちの顔を見て
おはようじゃなくて 何て言いますか
初めて会うと何て言います？はじめまして
よろしくお願いしますと
という気持ち 本当にはじめましてという気持ちになったら
何のトラブルもないでしょうに
誰もはじめましての人とトラブル起こします？起こしません
すごい楽しいんです 人に会って
だから自分自身もはじめましての状態だから
全く新しいだから そこに明日も明後日もないんです
昨日もないんです そこで苦しみもないんです
子供を朝見たら もう子供は昨日ものすごい喧嘩したんだと
家の中でいろんなものを壊したりとか
朝見たってもおはようと言うんだけど
昨日と似てるんですね
昨日の同じ子供やと だからそこにまた昨日というものを引きずっているんだから
心は十分幸福を味わえないんです
で はじめましてにならないんです
だから無常に逆らうんだから
みんな不幸だけ 無常になりきっちゃえば幸福だけ
その方法なんです 仏教で仰っているのは
我々は瞑想ということで何を体験させるかというと
徹底的に一切は無常であることを体験させちゃうんです
いくら瞑想したっても
尊いもの 尊い何か 尊い仏様は如来様
大日如来様 どんな化け物
誰も出てこないんだと
観音様でも誰でも 神様でも誰でも見てみなさいと
瞬間瞬間 すべての現象が現れては消える
現れては消える そこで自分という妄想概念消えちゃう
ただ瞬間消滅する現象しか何もないのではないか
そこで あっ これを探していたんだという
あのすごい巨大な感激が生まれてくるんです
それっきりで 誰見たっても
ああ これは田中さんだよ
田中さんはこの１９６７年３月２０日
私にそういうことを言いましたとかね
私から五千円借りていまだに貸してくれてないんだとか
四十年経ってもその恨み持ってるとかね
それはなくなっちゃうんです
だからそこで幸福が出てくるんです
ですから 幸福を味わいたければ
もう無常を体験するしか道がないんです
無常体験といったら 瞬間ははじめましてというふうな感じで
もう過去もないし 将来もないし
将来ないというのは暗い言葉なんですけど
もう過去の引きずれることもないし
将来に希望する悩む問題もないし
明日どうしようかということないんだから
別に 今日だけだから 今だけだから
今だけだったら何の問題もないでしょうに
それで まあそれは悟りの境地なんですけど
まあ悟らなくたって もう悟るまでは不幸になりなさいということはちょっとね
良くないしね ですから悟らなくてもいいというわけはないんだけど
悟るまでは不幸になることもちょっともったいないし
ですから 皆様方はもうそんな言い訳をしないで
私は悟らなかったんだからね
まだ悟ってないんだからという言い訳しないで
無常であることをよく頭でだけでも理解して
人生に使ってみてください
毎日 そうすると あの悟った方々が味わうほどの究極的な純粋な幸福感が味わえないかもしれませんだけど
人生は問題なく幸福にはなるんです
何のことなく すべての精神的に悩みは消えちゃう
毎日の生き方はいつでもまあ物事は無常ですから変化していくんだと
で 物事はだけではなくて
自分のこともすごく覚えてください
私はまあいつでも変化していくんだ
その生き方で その いわゆる何て言いますか
生きる時 我々には何かこの死地について考え方なければ
なんでみんななんか墓穴って生きてるんだけど
何のために生きてるか
なんか哲学持ってないんですね
それで哲学作る 上がる人々も何か将来の希望とか
あんな恐ろしくて気持ち悪いんです
例えばたまに言う子供たちに
あんた方はしっかり大きくなって
あの親をちゃんと助けてくださいとかね
冗談じゃないんで そういういろいろくだらない希望なんか付けたりして
ですから この別に希望的な哲学ではなくて
自分が瞬間瞬間変化していくこと
だからそんなに瞬間にこだわらないこと
物事も瞬間瞬間変化するんだということ
例えば人と喧嘩したんだと
どうったことないんで
その時は喧嘩しただけのことで
その人も変わるし 自分も変わるし
その哲学を理解して生きていられる
これにはもう普通の人は難しいんだけどね
でもかなり幸福になります
そんなにびっくりすることはないんですよ
世の中何何を見ても 今の子供はなんか学校を拒否してるんだな
登校拒否しているんだとか
そんなびっくりするほどの問題じゃないし
今の日本の経済状態はひどいんだとか
だから何ですかと 別にどうってことないんです
全部瞬間瞬間変わるし
経済状態良くなったっても驚く必要はありません
全然ないんです すぐ変わりますから
だから人生には大惨事ということもなくて
万々歳もそういうこともないんです
もう全部変わっていくんです
人間というのは何かいいことがあったら
もうお祝いして祝福して祭をするし
不幸に出会ったらものすごく落ち込んじゃって自殺までしちゃうし
バカバカらしいんです
どっちでも まあすごくいいことにあったっていうのは
まあね 事はいいことですけど
まあ大したことはない
それはすぐ消えるんだと
不幸になったら まあ大したことない
それもまあすぐ消えるもんだからといって冷静に大人しくすればいいのに
ですから 無常ということは
我々のこのフィロソフィー生きるための人間の生命の哲学として置いておけば
世の中は平和になるし
みんな幸福を感じるし
世の中からほとんどの苦しみは消えていっちゃうんです
一番素晴らしいのは この心の悩み
苦しみ 消えちゃう みんな心で悩んでいるのは
この過去に引きずられているんですね
人とそれから将来を心配しているんですね
それものすごいバカバカらしい考え方なんです
引きずっている過去が自分じゃないんだから
それで心配する将来の自分じゃないんだから
喧嘩してるんです ですから
過去に引きずられることも
将来にもう心配で悩むこともなく
すごくこのリラックスした状態で生きていられます
それには無常ということをこの哲学として
理想と 理想というんですか
理念として頭の中に入れておくだけ
別に無常だからって何とかする必要ないんです
すごい簡単です 仏教の方法っていうのは
無常だから何とか何とかしなくちゃ
そんな何もする必要ないんです
無常だから 接着剤でもこの無常な現象を一つつなげて一本にしてしてみようではなく
そんなことは それは宗教でやっていることで
あんた死んでも永遠の命あるんだからって言って
それは問題なんですから
苦しみだから 永遠というのは
過去を引きずらなくちゃいけないんだから
永遠の人は 将来心配しなくちゃいけないんだから
なぜならば永遠だから
ですから 何もすることないんです
ただ 瞬間瞬間 無常であることは理解しておく
それで幸福になります
で 仏教の瞑想っていうのはそういう働きであって
この無常っていうのをとことん体験させちゃう
それ体験する方々はまあ体験していくと
どんどんどんどんみんな経験します
自分の苦しみが消えていくわ
いろんな恨みも消えていくわ
人 人間観 今までいろんなガタガタした人間関係
なんとなく問題なくなっていくわ
体が病気であろうと別に心配する
心配しないようになるわ
結構うまくいっちゃうんです
それはまあ 瞑想の奇跡とかっていうのはもうでたらめないい加減な話で
瞑想の奇跡ではなくて
ごく自然的な結果なんです
心の悩みが消えちゃうと体も良くなってくるわけ
体も健康的になるし そういうふうなことで
我々は幸福をつかめなくちゃいけないんです
で それでもうちょっと忘れたことがあります
この心の中に生まれるこの快感みたいな
この喜悦感こそが幸福ですから
そこを作ればいいんです
普通の世界で我々は音楽を聴いたり
映画を見たり 舞台を見たり
美味しいご飯を食べたり
美味しい美しい服を着たり
家族を作ったりして その心の中でこの快感を感じようとしているんです
脳細胞を刺激してあげようと
幸福の刺激を でも 物質として刺激したっても
すぐ心がそれに慣れちゃって刺激にならないんですね
何でも一回だけなんですからね
ですから その道をやめちゃうと
例えばもう もう何でもね
もうたまたま一回できたところで楽しいんだけど
二回目 三回目だとあんまり楽しくないんですね
ですから この物に頼ると幸福は消えるんです
ご飯食べて楽しもうと思ったら幸福消えちゃうんです
ご飯食べちゃうと もうどんどんどんどん面白くなくなっちゃう
またわかりやすい例にします
例えばプロの野球の選手がボールを投げるんだと
百二十キロの速さで 素人の人にはもうバット
バットで打てるところからボールは見えないんですね
強烈に出てくるんだから
打つところじゃなくて逃げろという気持ちになっちゃうんです
それぐらい速さでプロがボールを投げるんだから
それでも素人の自分がそれでバットを持っていたところで当たっちゃったと
ボールに 当たったらすごい楽しいでしょうに
打てたぞと そこでその人はあ
打てるんだと思って二回目やったらどうなる？失敗です
三回も必ず失敗でしょうに
それで練習すればするほど失敗だらけでしょうに
プロにはとはもう敵わないんだから
もしその人は必死になって苦労して訓練して訓練して
とにかくそのピッチャー
ピッチャーというんですか
ボールね そのピッチャー
ピッチャーの球を球に打てるようになった時
楽しいですか？楽しくないんです
もうプロだから 自分も
でもやっとプロになったという楽しみがあるんだけど
でもその過程はすごい苦労した
そこでもうあのピッチャーだったらもう大丈夫やっていう状態になったら
もう打てても別になんのこともないんです
感激はない 細胞中も毛も立って楽しくてもうしょうがないという状態にはならない
打てたんだと ですから
このものに頼って刺激を得よう
快感を得ようとするとどうなるかというと
すぐ二回 三回繰り返しちゃうと
それわけ 僕何回も同じこと言いますけどね
たとえうなぎ美味しいといっても
朝も昼も夜も次の日も食べてみてください
もう気持ち悪くなるんで確実に
私は食べたことはないんだけど
もう一回食べる時にたまに想像してみるんです
みんな美味しいと言うんだから
この味は朝も昼も夜も
その時は気持ち悪くなって一回も食べられなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 人生っていうのはそんなもんで
だからといって幸福は刺激
この快感みたいなこの喜悦感だから
それはどうやって得ればいいんですか
それは直接心で作ればいいでしょうに
別に 何もなく